in terms of you know sort of goals you
know I I guess I'm again drawn to the
notion that the the there's certain
principles of justice or fairness or you
know you know societies that where
people can entertain each other well and
and and and and be constructive and be
part of a community and and the highest
calling that anybody can have is
actually to do something that improves
the lives of the community and of others
and again just it is it's sort of
repeating a theme that I've raised
already but it seems to me that that
that what we're trying to do ultimately
it is is make people have better lives
to give them more opportunities to do
whatever they they want to do to meet
the needs that they have for you know
housing in health care and and and
opportunity and you know how do we get
the rules right and how do we get the
ways of thinking right to enable that
better you know quality of life in
standard of living i guess that's that's
what that's how I kind of measure in
some sense the the underlying values now
there's some people that would say that
that would make a kind of a crisper
formulation of that they would say that
that you know the way to measure your
success or the measure of society
success is is is what happens to the
least fortunate you know the people that
have the least least money or the least
power the least of anything and can you
create a society that works for for the
least fortunate not not not others and I
again I subscribe to that as well I've
been very very interested in the in the
question of of of really creating
opportunity and I've been struck with
how that often happens at a very
grassroots level and some of the stuff
I'm working on and thinking about now is
is really its complementary to all the
other work but it's really some of the
most exciting
and memorable and powerful examples one
sees of economic development or not
grand government policies but but stuff
that it's at the very very grassroots
level where some people in the community
can find a way to work together to
create something value you know almost
against all odds and I think we need to
think and understand more about about
how how communities can can work
together constructively along these
lines a the thing I I'm panicked about
in terms of the times that we live in
now are the sort of inability of people
in different groups and segments of
society to work constructively together
on any legitimate social aim instead
everybody seems to be out for for their
own values are their own ideology or
their their their rewards economic
rewards or were there job security or
whatever we we have this kind of
adversarial you know view of how society
works now where where it's us versus
them and and you know one of the central
themes in my work is that there's these
there's gigantic win-win opportunities
where where you can benefit the
environment but you can benefit the
company you know you can you know you
can you can make make the patient be
better off but also the health plan will
will benefit there's there's these wind
moon opportunities and for some reason
now we're very much in a zero-sum world
where everybody's kind of fighting with
with a perspective that you know my
witness is your loss or and again that
and that troubles me a lot
you